all right luciano
legiano uh where'd you grow up where you
from originally
i'm really from right here south central
l.a
and tell me about you how you grew up um
i grew up in a two-parent home um
my dad worked two jobs but um i grew up
right there in the projects
right then the pebble de la rios and the
[ __ ] and garden projects too as well
and how would you describe your
childhood
to me moms i don't know i'm a i'm a lone
star like i got a
big family but i'm always by myself i
like to do things solo
i like to get you know be in my own
little world but um i grew up
i grew up in a very good i mean a great
family you know
um
i got gang brothers and sisters i'm
guess like 16 brothers 14 sisters so
y'all got a big family
you went through high school yeah i went
to high school graduated
um when i graduated in nicotine
well um
what's that continuation ged
continuation yeah but you got through
yeah did you have dreams of uh doing
something with your life when you were
young
you're still young how old are you 231
31 yeah you're young
yeah um i had
dreams doing a lot of things uh
music was one of them um
but um i like to write though mostly
anything
you see me um big reading read anything
it doesn't matter what it is i'll pick
it up and read it
but here you are in the streets yeah
because it epidemic
um i originally got out
i only been out for like maybe a year
two months from where
from rockstar state prison but i went to
courtroom
i did um my last couple of months in the
shoe program
are we in there for um but they found
narcotics in my
my room you feel me but um my release
date
my relief they beat them to them what
beat the investigation so
but they still got two years to follow
me though anytime anytime they want to
but i mean what can i say so so you're
you're helping some of the girls though
on fig right
you can say that you feel me um
i basically let them do them feel me at
them today whether they're with me or
not they'll be out there doing it anyway
you feel me so it's just money
management i'm like a bank
how how do you describe your role in
their lives
by this moment and they just need
structure they just looking for a home a
place to be
you see me they looking for love too at
the same time
but i mean i don't cover nothing with
them no none of that after the day
they know what time it is i'm just going
to do me
but the girl i mean they coming along
they fine
from um little issues every now and then
but not too much i can't handle
do you see yourself almost as a like a
life coach
you give them guidance i'm gonna say a
motivational
i figure at the day i'm not trying to
break my girlfriend i'm trying to uplift
them
see i'm trying to motivate keep keep
going
continue to go get it and then they you
see me
like my little brother for me he don't
um
he rapping he's on youtube and all that
you feel me call him ko you hear me um
he said um watts w-a-t-t-s we are taught
to survive
so i mean it wasn't the truth though we
really are
but i mean the girl got to do what they
got to do
just like i got to do what i got to do
after the day i'm just on the street so
either
you feel me i make moves and do other
things
i'm not just sitting there watching him
and all that
and what what kind of guidance will you
give them
because some of their past little
situations with other people and all
that
other people that i'm being with like
it's like a form of torture i just meant
to break them down to build them back
up like i'm trying to wipe all that out
like all that
what they were doing burning them girl
um
putting them in cold water like someone
started out in here it's like amazing
for real for them but they strong though
they survived
everything they keep going so
so you see what you do is kind of as
you're helping you're helping build them
back up
basically because then they gotta be out
there like that they can do other stuff
i mean whether they choose to do with
their money or not whether they give it
to me or give it to the next person
at the end of the day you feel me it's
their decision it ain't mine
how many girls you do this with right
now
i'm currently at maybe 16 17 girls right
now
but some get along some don't so
the ones who don't they got to get it
wrong by themselves or whatever
and this is a romantic or a sexual
relationship with some of them
not only one of them only one of them
only one of them but
with the others
i mean what does it i mean it is what it
is i mean what can i say
right are drugs a part of your life um
for our marijuana you you feel me um
i don't drink from i just know marijuana
that's it
that's it i mean a lot of the girls are
using sir
some some do but i don't really like it
but at the same time i'm not just
try to force them to do anything today i
think they they growing women they gonna
do what they want to do
you feel me and then they don't
know if i get what i need i ain't [ __ ]
they're free to go
right if we go do whatever they want i'm
not about to take all your stuff none of
that
and today i bought it for you you can
have it do your thing
and then they ain't nobody gonna treat
you like me anyway so go ahead
and tell you they really don't even want
to leave do the girls come to you
do the girls choose you or do you no
they choose me yeah
you feel me today i feel like
all the girls i got they all chose me
yeah you seen me
i accepted them but for sure they chose
me
right because i don't go out there
scouting and looking
i mean they see some obvious they like
me do you have a
any uh gang history
um you can say that from
part of the west side of the lanes the
streets
the streets the gangs i associate
but not like that you know i'm in and
out
i'll let them do them i'm gonna do me i
ain't worried about
the street politics and what goes on in
the streets i'm worried about me
i'm worried about what people think
about me what they gotta say you know
none of that
doesn't matter it's your opinion i
really don't give a [ __ ] about your
opinion
do you have kids of your own yeah i got
kids on my own
and are you raising them
somewhere but not really but
i mean if my kids come when they come to
me they ask me
i i'm just right there you know what i'm
saying at the end of the day
i'm in a little situation with my kids
well we're not with them but
with the parents we don't always see our
diet so
i think they they know i love my kids
but
i ain't about them and then i could have
another one
period yeah one of your girls is
pregnant right one of your girls is
pregnant right yeah we
might be having 20. twins
how many kids do you have already it's
gonna be my fourth one
i mean the twins gonna be if they're
twins for sure gonna be four
i only got two right now i had a boy and
a girl i got a son that's 16.
about to go play football college
football i got a daughter that's
12. she's still getting to know herself
so
i mean i'm here for them whenever they
need
but before their mom ago
ain't got nothing to do with my kids
what personality trait do you possess
that makes this
situation that you've built possible
where where multiple women are coming to
you for guidance giving you their money
all that kind of stuff
no i'm not i'm just me i'm just myself i
don't know
people could just the assumption that uh
oh i talk like a player i might be a
pimp or whatever i mean
and they if they see it that way i guess
that's what it is but i don't see it
that way
you don't think they like i said i'm not
forcing them to do anything i'm not
beating on them i'm abusing them
none of that they can leave free to go
or whatever
i can take my me chasing money and all
that me doing what i'm doing never gonna
stop
the the word i hear on the street is
there's another personality another side
of your personality
what i'm seeing right now oh oh yeah for
sure
if so when i get mad and this is
it's it's a rap like i haven't seen that
but i've heard about it
yeah i mean it's it's devastating good
maybe the truth though i ain't gonna lie
be the truth but
my anger always get the best of me
that's why i like to get mad well
there's there's so much bs out there
i'm selfish and the way to deal with it
sometimes is
people lie so much they pretend to be
something they're not
is it difficult to be around so many
people that are that are hustlers that
are just
up to no good that are that are troubled
no i feel like i don't keep none of them
baskets around me man like
for sure if you grind me i'm gonna tear
it off top i removed him on my way
all i need is positive people around me
i mean that's it
no negativity no nothing if you ain't
trying to do nothing with your life then
yeah
go kick it with the people who ain't
trying to do nothing with their life
and then they i got a place at the beach
i'm trying to do something i'm trying to
get to where i need to go
move on my way defend me i'm gonna go
around you over you
under you at the day man i pretend like
i only see people half of the time
you mean most time people come to me
they be talking i really don't be
listening
i'll be my might be somewhere else
somebody told me the other day like
like you wake like every all day every
day is
money on your mind that's all you think
about for sure i eat brief [ __ ]
money that's all i'm thinking about
that's all i've been thinking about
that's all i've been chasing i'm gonna
go get it what's more important to you
money or love
tell you i'm me
right now i'mma say
neither one because i'm not
materialistic i don't really care about
money
for me but for shovel show i will hold
on to it
but if you ask me for it i'll give it to
you because just as fast
i'll give it to you just the fact i'm
gonna make it back what's most important
to you
loyalty that's it that's all i care
about
you hear me and then they long as you're
doing what you're supposed to do
and you all i'm trying to do is motivate
people to keep going out there to go
do what you got to do stop trying to be
lazy and all that [ __ ] on your ass
don't do nothing my sister work free job
shouldn't get up every morning you know
what i'm saying
what the hell i look like laying right
there why she get up every morning you
know hell no i'm gonna go get it too
so just when she was getting up if i
wasn't up before her she was up before
me
but the show we was up both leaving out
the door right behind each other
so so many people see that
with the girls that we're talking about
girls that work figaro for example
do for a living is is wrong and the
girls are being
forced into that or it's just not right
for them to be doing it
i mean but at the same time then people
looking from the outside
they're not this person they're not
living their life what do you think most
outsiders don't understand about that
life
i think most of these girls don't have
no father figure around
most of these girls was right abused
you know saying this is the only thing
this is what they only know some of
these girls didn't even go to school
you feel me some did i know a lot of
them
went to school where they out there you
don't have to be but they choose to be
got good families and everything
well who am i to judge them and then
they
leave their god live your life if that's
how they want to live life
let them live it you see me period
leave them alone is your attitude that
they're going to be out there doing it
anyway
they're lost and they need some guidance
i mean i feel like this
as people we're not perfect we ain't god
that was the only person that was
perfect we all make mistakes
from but who am i to judge them on their
mistakes
whether they learn from them or not at
the day they gotta they gotta live their
life they gotta go through what they
gotta go through
and then it's light at the end of the
tunnel period can't
it can't be too many much dark nights
and stormy days you know what i'm saying
[Music]
when they ready to quit when they're
ready to see that light at the end of
the tunnel
they'll go get it someone make it
someone and the ones who want to still
be out there
when we loan dead and gone is they still
living or whatever they'll still be out
there
tell me your thoughts on karma on karma
yeah i don't believe in it
i don't believe in it i don't believe in
karma and today
i feel like people do wrong at the day
it's just common sense right and wrong
at the day you know what you're doing is
wrong
if you choose to continue to do that
then that's what you continue to do
i want to be treated how i want others
to treat me so for sure
show my kind i'm gonna be respectful as
soon as you disrespect me
oh for sure i'm gonna disrespect your
ass back
no i'm saying so but i'm respect
everybody
i don't care if i don't know you i'm
gonna respect everybody
but people they see me when they see me
come in they oh he's a thug
he didn't until i told him to speak and
then it's like oh no
but sure i'm not dumb at all whatsoever
but i'll let people do what they do
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
patience and um to understand people
for some reason i can just talk to a
person i can just
just get it just like i don't have to be
told like oh you know something you know
i already know
for sure all these girls ain't got it
they ain't got it all
and the ones who do they're the lucky
one
but for them girls to be doing drugs and
selling their body and been through the
abuse and the rape and everything like
that
you feel me they use the drug at the
gateway they use sex as a getaway
some don't like it some do
but for sure if people really care
people be out there helping them girls
you feel me out there with condoms
walking down the street you feel me
your girl ain't got no place to go none
of that so you met the person
that's basically giving them home taking
babies taking care of them they can't
take care of themselves
their family won't take care of them
because what they do
yeah this is the situation that i see
over and over again is that the drugs
are a big part of the picture
drugs makes drugs messed up
yeah i mean the crystal meth especially
oh yeah for sure that's just a new crack
error
it's a shovel show that's everywhere
mine was only
why you said hispanic doing mine black
doing it that's a whole new market
that's a whole new money thing
and then you get the riskier sex
requests yeah and then the whole thing
just kind of
problems spread from there i understand
that different drugs affect different
people different
we can hit the same drug you will die or
go crazy and i'll still be the same
person
that's amazing to me that's crazy
but it it's like that somebody hear
something and
for sure this person that hit it well
nothing happened he
hit it and he'll die
just off one hit yeah
but the different behaviors you see from
people oh yeah fulfill them yeah the
tricks are high the girls are
high very often but
that drug really drove down prices
for me you got a crackhead out here
giving head for 20
15 then you got a girl real hoe out here
who really trying to get her money she
charging me at 60
maybe 75 dollars for sure he don't want
that he rather go get his dick checked
by the crackhead
you see me didn't go get one by a decent
girl that's clean and all that you ain't
got to worry about nothing
but they wouldn't take the risk and some
of these cars
be amazing i mean how many do the loan
officers um
working corrections and government it'd
be crazy because they wanted some of the
weirdest [ __ ] ever
the girlfriend experience that's just
crazy
they want to bare back go kissing and
all that like you want to kiss on a
prostitute
you want to go bare back with across the
street like for sure show
that is some weird crazy [ __ ] i just
don't know
but good thing about him to show people
keep their girls clean
make sure they stay with congress and
everything you feel me i think they
for sure she gonna do it she's my wife
[ __ ] be safe doing it
you don't want to lose your girls no
aids or you feel me especially
overdosing on drugs so for sure
and nothing about that and some of these
parents actually
take care of these kids and send their
kids to daycare and [ __ ] like this this
[ __ ]
i'm just saying but for sure the new age
coming is
dumb as hell showboating all on feb
making a scene of themselves flossing
with these girls money
you your family ain't really doing
nothing with it some starting businesses
and then they just the whole point is to
get the girls off the street
make enough money off the streets and
put them into business is where they
continue to make the money bring the
money back
you know i'm saying doing something
different doing something positive
so what they're gonna have live that
they own some that go some don't but
i just learned to be patient and be able
to learn people
be able to read people
how would you describe yourself would
you call yourself a pimp or you would
call yourself a hustler
one of the girls one of the girls i
interviewed recently royalty called uh
some guys uh
uh whole hustlers oh pimps is the
biggest hoes ever
how would you describe yourself i mean
i know i'm i'm just i'm just simple
like i ain't no hustler i ain't no
connor i ain't money hungry
no none of that i'm just like i just
want to live i don't want to survive
[ __ ] surviving i'm going to live like
everybody else is living
maybe even better
if you want it you're gonna go get it if
you don't [ __ ] you'll be out here on
skid row
walking around with them luciano thank
you so much for sharing your story
yeah i wish you the best of luck out
there man all right thank you thank you
you